Mike, Alex, welcome
back to the forge.
You've had five days at
your home forge just to work
on your horseman's axes.
Mike, tell us about your weapon.
It's a little rough
around the edges
but I think it
will perform well,
and I can't wait
to see it happen.
WILL: Alex?
Everything just
fell into place
for me, even though I had to
make some last minute changes.
And I'm looking forward
to seeing it tear
apart some ballistics dummies.
All right, gentlemen.
Up first, the kill test.
Doug?
The horseman's ax is
actually two weapons in one.
It's got an edge that
can lascerate and chop
and a spike that can
penetrate and crush bones.
To see what kind of lethal
damage your ax will do,
I will take your horseman's
ax and deliver lethal blows
on this ballistics dummy.
Mike, you're up first.
You ready?
MIKE: Yes, I am.
[music playing]
[whispering]
Well Mike, let's
talk about your weapon.
Your edge over here is sharp.
It lacerated deep into
the bowels right here.
Your spike definitely caved
in all the way into the chest
and straight into the heart.
The only issue we have
is that your handle is
a little bit on
the rounded side,
so there is a tendency
to slightly roll.
But overall, your
weapon will kill.
Thank you.
Alex, you're up next.
You ready?
Yes.
DOUG: Let's do this.
ALEX: All right.
I'm pretty proud
of what I created.
It's just a little
heavy, and that's
a bit of a concern going in.
[music playing]
Sweet.
Alex, your weapon here is a
little bit on the heavy side.
But you know what?
It is well balanced.
The edge of your blade here
cut deep in the chest cavity
and it broke the bones.
Your spike here,
right into the heart.
And of course, on the swing, it
pretty much just disemboweled
the dummy right there.
Your weapon will kill.
Yes.
Thank you.
DOUG: Next up is
the strength test.
Jake?
Now we know ice can be
very brutal on an edge.
So I'm going to take
your horseman's axes
and repeatedly strike into
these large blocks of ice
to see how well they hold up.
Mike, you're up first.
You ready?
Yes, I am.
Going into the ice
block test, I'm
concerned there may be a fail
point in the head handle area.
[music playing]
Well Mike, unfortunately
we had a serious failure
on your ax with this weld
point in the junction
of the belt hook.
Alex, you still have
to pass this test.
You ready?
- Yes, I'm ready.
There's only one thing standing
between me and a $10,000 check,
and it's really big,
and it's made of ice.
[music playing]
Alex, your horseman's ax
did quite a job on that ice.
Everything's still tight, your
edge is still razor sharp.
Thank you.
So all in all,
very nicely done.
Bladesmiths, our
weapons tests here
are designed to be
exceptionally brutal
in order to set your weapons
apart from one another.
Mike, your blade did not
survive our strength test.
For that reason, I have to ask
you to please leave the forge.
OK.
I am disappointed
but when I go home,
I'm going to have
a smile on my face.
Forged in fire has risen
me from the dead somehow.
I will take this forward with
me for the rest of my life.